hello everyone and welcome to game 5 of
the World Chess Championship match
between Yani pomishi and the dean liren
uh so far we've had four very exciting
games and uh game five I'm not gonna
spoil it for everyone but it's uh you
know could be the most exciting one yet
now we've had some exciting draws we've
had some exciting decisive games I'm not
gonna say too much uh so let's just dive
straight into the game uh before we
actually check out the game here is a
nice uh a couple of seconds clip from
the game there you have ding just to
give you an idea of how the players are
prepared for the game uh perfectly still
like like a picture and Nepal so can't
uh can't wait for the game begin I know
some of you would like to see this again
so I'm gonna play it again uh some of
you might have missed it so there we
have it it's only a few seconds so uh
you know just to get in the mood for the
game and the first move was made by this
gentleman here I don't know who he is if
you have any insight in that to do share
uh in in the comment section so we can
all increase our knowledge as well now
that being said let's check out the game
so everyone one I was interested in
whether Nepal will try D4 or will he go
Knight to F3 will he go C4 but he
actually repeats Ponte e for the move he
opened the World Chess Championship with
and we have E5 from ding uh no one was
uh actually thinking that Dean would
reply with anything other than E5 to E4
because he's an E5 player but who knows
they might have also something else in
store if Nepal gets really really
promising positions with E4 so okay
Knight to F3 Knights the C6 and Bishop
to B5 dorui Lopez is in the is on the
board the same as we've had in game one
Ponte A6 morphe's defense Bishop to A4
and now Knight to F6 we have castles and
now Bishop to A7 and here uh if you guys
remember D3 is a very popular move but
the most popular move here is Rook to E1
there are like 40 000 games where Rook
de one was played uh in game one that
ended in a draw Bishop captures and C6
was played which was a big surprise by
nepo but here we have D3 and we sort of
um continue in the known Waters this is
the Martinez variation of the real Lopez
uh the second most popular uh line and
okay Ponte B5 biting with Bishop to D3
uh B3 D6 C3 and now uh castles biting
with H3 and Bishop to B7 so nicely uh
putting pieces on optimal squares and
pawn to A4 now it's interesting uh the
only uh game in the database with this
exact same position is algresa firuja
with the white pieces against anijigiri
from the FDX cryptocup 2020 or maybe
2022 yeah it's 2022 and uh
Anisha won very nicely with the white
pieces and this game continues pretty
much in the same fashion night day 5
with Bishop day two uh getting the
version part of Harm's Way Pawn to C5
and now in that game Knights the A3 was
the move that alireza used to beat Anish
giri but here we have Bishop to G5 and
it is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game now what's
interesting is about the G5 is that the
move alireza played Knight to A3 is sort
of a 0.00 but if you really let the
engine crunch the numbers it will give
Bishop G5 as a maybe a Sly favorite like
zero point zero five so nothing
spectacular but it just shows you that
Bishop to G5 is um uh something that
Nepal and his team put quite a lot of
effort in so how can ding continue
playing this obviously he has a lot to
consider one of the ideas is uh always
spawn to C4 can he play this if he can
disrupt the white strong Center uh then
it's definitely worth it but here if you
go for it let's say this uh C4 move then
Knight to A3 is actually fairly strong
and now I see captures on D3 let's say
you trade Knights here you wanna gain
more control over the D5 Square let's
say captures captures Queen captures on
D3 and now you have uh from control of
the D5 square and you should have a very
comfortable game even if B captures an
A4 you don't really care about being
down upon for the moment you will get
excellent position for your pieces let's
say captures captures now you have
control over D5 the um double a pawn
isn't all that spectacular so you know
it's a game but ding doesn't go for that
after Bishop the G5 ding actually goes
for Pawn to H6 now he forces matters
Bishop captures with Bishop captures and
now a captures on B5 by on we have eight
captures and now Knight beta D2 and now
again uh you could play D5 here because
it's uh it's sort of a backward spawn
you don't want it on D6 but um for the
moment you can play it the D5 uh it's um
it's a move that kind of releases all
the tension but then it's a question how
weak are the BC and the e-pawn after you
push a
upon the D5 so a thing just keeps the
tension he plays Knight to C6 and okay
now we have uh this very nice Bishop to
D5 move and uh how do you continue here
well obviously you have to ask yourself
uh do you want to play Knight D7 and
trade Bishops right away which you can
uh but a ding doesn't seem to be rushing
anything here instead he plays a rook
captures on A1 we have Queen characters
on A1 and now Queen to D7 just keeping
the tension uh Rook to E1 by nipple and
now we have Rook to A8 again Knight to
A7 is always an option then we trade and
then uh it's it's it's basically a
question of uh are your pawns safe or
can white put some pressure on those
pawns if white can't then you've uh
pretty much solved all of your problems
but okay dingo's Rook 38 he attacks the
queen and nepo brings the queen back to
the starting Square Queen to D1 with
Bishop back to d8 and this is one of the
more interesting uh moments in the game
being it's the needs to figure out how
to get this bishop to actually do
something in this game one of the ways
to do that is to play something like G6
Bishop G7 and H5 and the other one is to
shift the bishop over to B6 to gain
control over this diagonal which is what
the ding goes for and the situation on
the clock here is very interesting
nipple uh spent pretty much two minutes
here he has an hour and 57 minutes and
the ding is already down to 1 hour and
12 minutes so it's a quite substantial
almost uh like like a 50 minute hour gap
so Knight to F1 now nepo needs to figure
out how to get this Knight to a more
active square and another thing if you
even if you trade the Bishops here then
the Knight can come to F1 to E3 and then
to D5 and then it's gonna be a monster
Knight yes you can put this Knight the
E7 to contest it but that means your
knight will not remove from E7 for for
the rest of the game and uh other than
that white has two knights so also
something to consider so Knight to F1 we
have Knight to the E7 and now Bishop
captures and B7 Queen capture some B7
and now Knight the E3 so the D5 square
is now Within Reach but also we can't
forget about Knight to F5 also Knight to
G4 also Knights the H due to G4 so
Knights the H4 to F5 all of these Knight
jumps are possible and the the real
question is whether this bishop is uh at
all uh useful as one of the one of uh
Nepal's Knights so here we have Bishop
to B6 and now Pawn to H4 by nipple now
uh with ideas of Ponte H5 uh clearing
the H4 Square for this Knight and the
ding dreams of pushing C4 which is um
usually not the case usually you dream
of pushing B for but here C4 is the move
you have to play you've already put your
Bishop on B6 so if you want the bishop
to be operational along this diagonal uh
C4 is the move that you will have to
play so here after uh the spawn H4 we've
Queen to C6 now preparing C4 and nipple
just ignores him you could play Queen to
E2 it's definitely an option for example
Queen T2 now this is sort of guarded but
then you
and it's a really weird position like if
H5 now c4 can be played and the entire
position opens up let's say decaltres
and C uh for now the bishop gladly is
given for the Knight here and if C
captures on B5 attacking the queen
there's Queen captures on e4 and now you
have captures on E3 there's Knight to
the D5 and um
um this is a bit too too double-edged
maybe to allow uh uh to allow black so
instead just Pawn to H5 nipple keeps the
tension now clears the H4 Square for his
Knight and now Pawn to C4 ding playset
and he opens up his dark Square bishop
and now nipple plays Pawn to D4 he
closes it and it's not easy to find the
move here for the now you could just
ignore Pawn to D4 you could play Rook to
d8 keep the tension and that's it and it
it is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine uh but it's
hard to make such a non-committal move
uh or a middle move uh depends on how
you look at it in a wheelchair's
championship match uh another thing you
could do is of course capture uh you you
don't uh for example if if you capture
which was played in the game uh you
might consider something like C
characters and D4 but then you have this
two to one advantage that black has on
the queen side and then Pawn to B for
Pawn to C3 at some point a pass Pawn
will be created and uh you're again
giving black a bit too much so a nip of
course knows that he has to play Knight
captures on D4 not C captures on D4 he
attacks the queen and now ding plays
Queen to C5 which is a way to keep the
game going if ding goes back Queen to B7
then we basically trade everything down
then Knight E to F5 comes then we trade
let's say Bishop captures on the four
Queen captures on D4 Knight captures on
f5e captures and queen to D7 and it's uh
some sort of a weird drawish position
where if F6 is played which is kind of
the move you want to play if you wanna
attack black then Rook the E8 forces a
rook trade attacks The Rook honey one
let's say Rook captures Queen captures
and now you might even play Queen
captures on D6 but now Queen T1 checking
H2 and queen captures on F2 and you will
always have a Perpetual here so not not
much to look for for if if you wanna
keep the game going so while possible
ding decides to go for Queen to C5 he
puts pressure on this diagonal and now
nipple needs to make a decision does he
want to play Queen to F3 or does he want
to completely disregard that he's weak
along this diagonal and play Queen to G4
now Queen to F3 is the move that solid
players would make and queen to G4 is a
move that a player like nepo would make
us heal you know he never tries out from
making uh such uh awesome sacrificing
moves uh I'm not sacrificing in material
but you know just in position I will
show you what happens nepo did play
Queen to G4 but if Queen to F3 then the
point is and probably why nepo didn't
play it is that after Queen to G5 now
the point is E5 attacks the rook and A8
you have to play Pawn to D5 and now it
doesn't seem like white has a way to
continue the game but there is this a
very very cool Pawn to E6 move and now
uh it's very hard to continue the
problem is let's say Rook to f8 and
there's this very nasty Rook day one and
the black doesn't seem to have a a good
response you can never capture this
because just Queen captures an f8 and
it's uh game over captures now good
night captures with check for for the
king and the queen uh so you know after
after E6 it's uh it's a very hard
position for black not not a lot of
moves here uh but okay nepo instead of
Queen to F3 we went for Queen to G4 and
this makes the game all the more
interesting because now we have Queen to
E5 by Dink and now Knight back to F3 uh
if you not continue with knight uh
Knight E to F5 ninja snap captures
Knight captures and King to H7 and you
don't have all that much the queen for
me five guards the G7 Pawn it's uh you
don't have Knight captures on H6 or
anything it's nothing spectacular you
don't have a rook lift uh even if you
did uh the queen covers H2 you can't
allow Rook day one check so not not a
lot I mean there's nothing here so
instead Knight to F3 nipple has to keep
the tension in order to keep the game
going Queen to E6 offering a queen trade
and now night there 5 just keeping the
tension uh you know it's uh it's a it's
a really fine position and ding has to
decide he could play Queen to F6 in in
the game he just traded Knight captures
on F5 but Queen to F6 was uh the move to
find because now how do you continue
with white there's uh not much you could
just go back Knight to G3 but then we
could repeat moves here Knight to F5
Queen F6 Knight to G3 Queen D6 Knight to
F5 and so on so basically after Queen to
F6 you're left with Knight captures on
E7 with check Queen captures and now
let's say queen to F5 uh going uh for
that B5 pawn and his Bishop the C5 Queen
to D5 goes after The Rook now you move
the Rook somewhere and the game
continues it's again uh pretty good for
black not not a lot to worry here the B5
Pawn is a little weak but uh there is no
way for white to actually do something
about that uh at some point the white
will try to get a knight five but the D4
Pawn is also weak your weak alongside
this diagonal so it's it's a fair
trade-off but okay after Knight to F5 uh
ding just traded Knight captures on F5
with e captures on F5 and now Queen to
F6 and now it's a little bit different
now nipple plays Queen to E4 and uh he's
attacking The Rook ding needs to react
to this he plays Rook to B8 prevents any
a queen infiltrations and also once the
bishop moves B4 is an idea because being
played C4 but B4 is the move you have to
play in order to really uh close this
game uh and now how do you continue uh
Nepal plays Rook to E2 which is a very
classy move it's in fact the top move
recommended by the engine because the
Hasty Pawn to G4 is met with Pawn to B4
that's the problem and now uh let's say
we play Queen captures and C4 there's B
captors and C3 and if B captures you're
kind of happy because you're up a pawn
but then D5 lands and now after captures
and captures yes you're still up a pawn
but it's a double death pawn and your
king is a little bit weak uh so it's not
not a position to celebrate uh so
instead Rook the E2 this now allows that
if dingo's uh Pawn to B4 which Now isn't
very impressive just C captures on B4
the pawn on B2 is defended by the rook
and now Rook to E2 basically uh prepares
this uh Ponto G5 push so after Rook D2
uh ding played Bishop to C5 and now how
can I now want to be for might again be
considered but now nepo just played Pawn
to G4 and again nipple has over an hour
on the clock he's an hour and six
minutes on the clock and ding has 35
minutes on the clock so here we have
Queen back to d8 now ding has to figure
out a way how to how to stop this
Onslaught the pawns are coming forward
uh and he's hoping to get something like
Queen to B7 and maybe trade Queens here
but Nepal just goes uh Queen to D5
there's even a spectacular uh mating
pattern here for example if uh King to
G2 is played then Queen to B7 now going
for Queen to B7 now there's this uh
amazing Knight to H4 move and now look
at this if Queen to B7 forcing a queen
trade you happily trade Queen captures
through captors who Rook to E8 with
check and now King to H7 and it seems
like black escapes but now Knight to G6
and there's no defending against
Checkmate uh you could capture but then
just cap doctors and this will now be a
Checkmate so very unfortunate for the
black king so instead after Queen to d8
a nipple went Queen to D5 which is also
an incredibly strong move and now King
the f8 biting he doesn't try anything
like this for cos King to f8 and now we
have King to F1 King to F1 is a very
tricky move because it's a move 35 and
ding needs to make five more moves to
reach time control and the point is if
nipple if ding now tries to trade Queens
let the queen to see it
um and go for something like this or
even stop F6 because of Queen captures
and G4 King F1 basically sidestep this
because Queen captures and G4 will no
longer come with check and here you will
be able to play F6 Queen captures on G4
uh and now uh how do you continue uh
look at this Rook to E7 new thread and
Checkmate and once one check is given
you're gonna move the king and that's it
next move you get um yeah you just get
checkmated so basically after F6 you
will have to play G captures on F6 but
it's not much better Queen E4 and you've
completely infiltrated the black skiing
side you have to go King to G8 uh and
now something like Knights to H4 and I
mean all of these weaknesses you will
not be uh you will not be able to play
this uh it's very hard to play this and
you will not be able to do it but it is
the best uh being has however being
played Rook the C8 here and it seems
like there shouldn't be anything here
but there is a way to do it if you only
allow the the engine a little bit of
time the engine doesn't see it but if
you really give the engine time to
Crunch the numbers uh then the engine
finds the move that nipple played here
and it's the only winning move so I'm
sure for those of you who haven't seen
the game you will be able to find it uh
feel free to pause the video here and to
win the game for nepo uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
absolute positional
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is a rook the
E4 the point is you're preparing Pawn to
G5 and once you upon the G5 lens then
Rook to G4 will be just uh deadly and
this is where ding realized it and he
realized that he doesn't really have any
moves he played Rook the B8 uh which
doesn't do all that much uh but not just
Pawn to G5 this is Unstoppable uh H
captures on G5 and now Rook to G4 and
now again not much to uh to be done here
the problem is F6 seems like it uh holds
everything but look at this Knight's the
H4 and now how are you stopping Knights
the G6 Knight the G6 once this lens uh
it's over and if you accept the Knight
sacrifice then just H6 and again it's
the same thing there's no no defense
against this so that's the problem with
an apple Rook the G4 just a brilliant
brilliant Rook lift this uh Rook D4 idea
so here the being tried Rook to A8 and
the problem is okay it's move 38 but
ding is only uh one minute on the clock
maybe one minute and 20 seconds so it's
um I mean it's terrible to be in his in
his shoes here and Nepal uh plays the
strongest move Knight captures on G5
never playing really the one of the
finest games of his life we have Rook
day one with check and now nepo goes
King to E2 which is uh which is winning
uh and this is uh he probably didn't
want to put too much pressure on ding
because this is move 40 and it would put
a lot of pressure ending but the problem
is if he plays King to G2 it's very
straightforward what the ding's next
move will be it will be a queen T8 and
then ding will get additional time uh it
uh okay he will be given additional time
but the position is completely winning
and I will just show it because it's uh
so spectacular look at this queen
captures an A8 Rook captures an A8 and
now Pawn to F6 now you don't really have
a way of dealing with this doesn't
matter if you capture if you don't the H
Pawn will become a past on so G captures
night stage 7 check forcing the king
away from the G file King to E7 now Rook
the E4 with check you can't go to f8 so
you have to go to D7 Knight captures on
F6 would check King has the move and now
Rook to d8 and blocks the rook and now
the H Pawn is Unstoppable regardless of
whether your trade Rooks or not even if
captures captures uh you don't have the
D4 Square you cannot stop the the past H
Pawn so this is a completely crushing
for nipple but nippo didn't go King G2
he went King to E2 sort of allowing a
few checks for thing but it doesn't
matter Queen to E7 with check was played
and now Knight to E4 and here everyone
thought that the ding would just resign
but ding did not resign he was granted
additional time because move 40 has been
reached and the ding actually found some
very nice defensive resources here and
it's uh it's very instructive and very
uh you know inspirational because uh
we've all been in these situations where
you can just resign but it's you know oh
always make your opponent work for his
meal never never just give it to him for
free and here we have Queen to E8 biting
now I'm just gonna show you what happens
if you play something like B4 the
problem with B4 is that Rook captures on
G7 uh and black resigns if King cap
respond to F6 with check wins the queen
and if you don't play that let's say you
play Rook day two which is also a fine
move uh let's say F6 and now after Rook
captures on B2 with check you even allow
this King to D1 no it doesn't matter if
you check the King again just King C2
and if you don't you have to do
something about the spawn G captures now
Queen to A8 with check and the King has
no squares you have to block and now
Rook the G8 check wins The Black Queen
again so in two lines that we've checked
the black loses the queen so ding finds
the only line where he keeps the queen
which is Queen to E8 and now we have
King to F3 by nipple uh and uh it's uh
definitely the way to go you could play
some other moves about the king to F3 is
just a very nice and also it just unpins
from the knight uh just for fun because
this is winning in so many ways I'm
gonna show you a a fine one and uh it's
it's very similar because after F6 uh G
characters and F6 and H6 it seems like
um now you're just lost but what about
the Rook the H1 is this playable in any
way not really King Tab 3 will be played
and you don't have a move here if Rook
captures on H6 you're just gonna play
Knight captures and C5 and that's it
black is down material you can't capture
back because if you capture back just
Queen captures and C5 with check and
it's the same trick uh so uh ding always
has to worry about this trick you're
gonna give a nice check here or or
something or you're just gonna or maybe
like this a rook to Jade with checking
captors or queen captures here and the
queen will of course overcome The Rook
so nipple basically plays that only he
knows that King to F3 uh will be a
useful move in that line so he just
plays it and the game I mean there's no
way for ding to improve his position so
here Queen to A8 is the only counter
play ding has and now nipple had to
calculated very precisely whether he has
a winning end game or not and he
calculates precisely he plays Queen
captures an A8 Rook captures an A8 and
now Pawn to F6 a move that comes in
every line because it just creates a
past H Pawn and The Rook cuts of the
king from the defense of the uh of the H
Pawn and now if G captures of course
just Knight captures and F6 there's no
move you can make here even this threat
of just winning The Rook so we're just
gonna move the king now Knights to G8
with check and that's it King 37 H6 and
there's no stopping the pawn The Rook is
helpless and the bishop is also helpless
notice how this bishop has been pretty
much helpless for the entire game even
though uh ding played some very very
awesome Maneuvers here with uh Shifting
the bishop over to this diagonal but the
bishop just
I had no had no purpose nipple just
completely outplayed the ding with this
setup so here G6 it's a very sub-optimal
move but uh positionally but ding has to
make it unfortunately H captors F
captures and Rook captures on G6 and now
uh nipple was shocked by ding's next
move and that is Rook to A2 and all of a
sudden from that position that was
completely tactically winning for him uh
he finds himself in this position where
okay he's up a pawn but it's a doubled F
Pawn is it really winning once ding
captures the B2 Pawn what uh what is
there uh well of course it is winning uh
but you could easily mess it up like uh
let's say you play Knight to G5 it seems
like a movie you really want to play
Knight H6 check and then you know you
just bring a Queen into the game the
problem is if Rook captures on B2 then
you have problems uh Rook captures and
F2 is coming and now it doesn't really
matter what you do not H7 tracking F7
Rook G7 King E6 Rook 37 check King to D5
and yes you can push but it doesn't
matter Rook captures with check King G3
and now whatever you play Black just
goes after this Pawn sure you can win
the black Rook doesn't really matter but
just Bishop D2 and you will have three
pawns for The Rook that are ready to
March forward and they will be
compensation enough for the Rook so
after Rook day two uh Nepal of course
did not go for that he played King to G4
and here we have Rook captures on B2 and
The Rook to H6 and it was in this
position on move 48 that dingler and
resigned to the game and the game 5 Goes
To None other than Yani promise who once
again takes the lead in the match and
now he has two wins nipple uh ding has
only one win and it is updating the uh
try and bounce back tomorrow tomorrow is
not a rest day tomorrow is also a play
day and the ding will have the white
pieces so we'll see what he uh and his
team come up with the try and bounce
back in this match but I mean it's uh
it's not gonna be easy and a lot of
people were saying uh okay uh Nepal just
uh you know completely fell apart like
in his world's championship match
against Magnus Carlson but now he just
came back and he played he played like
an absolute machine okay we've shown
that the positions on the board could
have been drawn but of course every
position can be drawn with perfect play
but here he just obliterates a former
2800 player uh you know in in absolute
positional style and interestingly out
of the last four games we've had three
decisive games and this is a World Chess
Championship Match I have no idea when
was the last time when there were three
decisive games in uh in in four games uh
definitely before 2013 I have no idea
which World Championship would that be
but we are seeing some incredible chests
here probably due to the fact that there
are players of opposite Styles like ding
is incredibly tactical but here you just
uh you just feel how real Lopez is such
a such a strong positional opening that
even dealing with his uh you know
incredible tactical sense was unable to
sense all of the all of the tactics that
could arise from such positions and yeah
if you guys are wondering why you resign
here is that you you have no move here
it's uh you're you're completely without
a move uh The Rook cannot capture
because the Knight covers the pawn and
the King will go to
G6 for example and Rook date it will be
Checkmate working the Jade will be
played then the pawn will be promoted to
a queen or if you capture the pawn here
with the bishop then Rook date checking
the F7 and King to F5 and the King has
no squares next move Knight captures and
D6 will be Checkmate uh Rook has no
checks or if you prevent this check that
night the G5 will be Checkmate so yeah
whatever thing does here it doesn't
really matter uh nipple played in
absolute master class and it will be it
will be very interesting how Dean comes
back from that and uh
uh what he and the uh what Henry had
rapper will prepare for his next game uh
with uh with the white pieces uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it very nicely done by both of them I
mean this has been a spectacular World
Chase Championship so far and out of the
fives yeah five games that we had uh so
so many decisive games and uh you all
know what comes next the next is game
six over World Chess Championship match
and everyone knows that game six is the
always the most uh special game of any
World Church Championship but let's hope
this one does not disappoint uh and
we'll see what happens tomorrow uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank muchas
from militaria Phil malthos Baxter read
fransley and Chris Johnstone for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
world cheers Championship until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon uh and have an excellent rest of
your day